je reçoive des charges à présent bonsoir
et bienvenue sur ce plateau président de
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à saint quentin en yvelines on
va évoquer vos prochains spectacles et
puis cette actualité également cette
émission sur france inter je te fais qui
vous était consacrée carnet de campagne
philippe van tran qui s'est penché le 15
mars dernier sur votre travail travail
que vous menez depuis dix ans pour
démocratiser l'opéra pour que
l'opération soit accessible aux enfants
et fait que des membres les quartiers
effectivement de tous les quartiers
je crois que c'est ce qui a intéressé
fille bertrand en fait nous avons été
cafter vous connaissez le principe de
l'émission
certes à une personne qui kft co2 des
associations ou des structures qui font
des choses très intéressantes dans le
domaine du social dans le domaine de
l'environnement et nous avons et on qui
étaient dénoncés j'ai eu un appel
téléphonique heureusement qu'elle
m'avait prévenu parce qu'elle nous a
rejoint l'association sinon j'aurais
j'aurai raccroché on m'aurait dit à
philippe bertrand qu'est en train de
vous appeler jeu ça dit quoi sérieux et
en fait on a été un peu on a passé une
bonne heure au téléphone avec ça son
assistante et là on a vraiment bien pu
évaluer toutes les choses et en fait je
suis passé voilà c'était le 15 mars
dernier cette émission vous pouvez
encore l'écouter sur le site internet de
france inter justement le lien qui va
qui va s'afficher n'hésitez pas à vous
en serez encore plus sur le travail que
vous menez alors l'idée on lisait ce
sont ces élèves issus de quartiers
défavorisés que la fée vous amener vers
l'opéra voilà en face au monstre a fait
depuis dix ans elle en fait j'ai
rencontré pierre michel durand qui était
à l'époque le chef associé jean claude
casadesus bien connu dans la musique
classique et même les les autres
puisqu'il passait souvent de son des
émissions de télévision donc chef
associé et lorsqu'il nous a rejoint nous
nous sommes rendus compte qu'il y avait
de moins en moins de public à paris pour
la musique classique il ya des salles
qui ont de moins en moins de public et
on s'est dit bon alors on va vers un
challenge on va créer un nouveau public
musique classique dans les cités et nous
sommes allés voir le maire de trappes
tout seul à aller voir la communauté
d'agglo 50 ans et demi à l'époque le san
et ils ont dit ok on a fait banco et on
a lancé cette première opération c'était
le clavier fantastique de graciane finzi
et nous avons 400 élèves issus des
classes de trappes des classes
d'elancourt à l'époque et pendant six
mois on les fait travailler dans l'est
dans leur classe on a les chefs de
choeur de très haut niveau qui les font
travailler travailler travailler à temps
et flasque vous arrive c'est un
spectacle rubens étonnant surtout à oui
oui avec sa première semblant pas la
toute première fois on m'a dit mais
attendez vous êtes fous là vous allez
pas me mettre ensemble des enfants de
des merisiers avec ceux du bois de les
gens ils vont sortir les couteaux de
banamba non non non et au contraire ils
sont mis alors c'est ça ça prend du
temps parce que tout ce qu'on a presque
ça a été simple ça a été monstrueuse
monde difficile au tout début
vous avez de ces enfants là au tout
début la première intervention il reste
pas dix secondes tranquille si vous
laissez c'est fou et puis petit à petit
il commence à rentrer et me demandais ce
que c'est du lard ou du cochon vous d'y
renoncer à ce que c'est sérieux ou non
et petit à petit après de parker tout
c'est toutes ces oeuvres est en finale
c'est étonnant parce que ils viennent
donc au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on avait monté
sa a vécu pire moutarde qui était le
directeur la scène nationale de l'époque
et là on a trouvé les 400 enfants sur
scène toute leur famille dans la salle
aussi parce que les facs et quand elles
conviennent aussi tout à fait normal
puisque ce sont des artistes donc les
artistes ont le droit d'inviter leurs
proches c'est toujours comme ça à salle
pleyel
même à l'époque les deux hymnes winz et
un vilain vitesse sa famille donc là ils
invitent leurs familles qui sont invités
gratuitement assister au spectacle
alors je vous dis pas la première année
ce phénomène
parce que il n'avait jamais mis les
pieds dans une salle de spectacle donc
ça criait ça hurlait c'est
l'enthousiasmé y avait pas un seul
applaudissements donc c'est
extraordinaire et ce qui nous a le plus
étonné c'est que les 400 enfants fait
hobbit obéissent au doigt et à l'oeil au
chef d'orchestre avec des choses
amusantes ce que j'avais déjà filé
bertrand et un moment où d'imaginer les
400 enfants j'adore qu'est ce qui fait
un grand signe pour mis à l'essai à son
égard au fond de la salle n'étaient qu'à
qui crie tragique et dean est
extraordinaire et là je crois que
c'était gagné alors à la fin les gens
criaient sauter tout média passé
l'applaudissement suis un peu inquiet et
puis finalement j'ai compris c'est qu'il
n'avait pas les codes en fait comme il
avait jamais m'y intéressais le
spectacle sait pas trop si on
applaudissait ou pense qu'une éducation
à faire voir une évocation est
maintenant c'est absolument étonnant
étonnant ce que tu disais à philippe
bertrand c'est que maintenant vous avez
plus un bruit et sauf que je lui disais
sol décrites parfois de bébé parce que
ces familles de trappes n'ont pas les
moyens de payer 2000 sitter donc elles
viennent avec leurs enfants et ça fait
partie de l'art et du comment se passe
le travail cette année parce que alors
cette année j'ai travaillé ça se
poursuit il y aurait une prestation
le spectacle aura lieu le 21 juin
donc la veille le vin nous avons une
générale publique
tout est gratuit un tout le monde est
invité donc il suffit de réserver sur
notre site internet ou le numéro de
téléphone que l'on verra je le crois
tout à l'heure est donc remise surgira
et le spectacle a lieu le 21 juin alors
cette année on a fait fort puisque ils
chanteront les plus grands opéras
français de la fin du xixème siècle où
les enfants chanter du carmen chanter du
gounod chanter du berlioz est là en ce
moment c'est exceptionnel il ya la chef
d'orchestre qui va revenir à une
deuxième fois dans les écoles et là
c'est magique parce que les enfants
c'est le dieu pour se payer un tel
travail intel tension que c'est pour eux
vraiment extraordinaire d'avoir le chef
d'orchestre qui vient et après plus ça
va plus ça monte en pression et le
spectacle final c'est un an la fin vous
savez toujours la même passion
même après 10 ans de oui oui parce qu'on
voit les résultats s'ils voulaient alors
vous savez vous amuser avec ses pâtures
très facile qu'il ya des gens qui nous
aident beaucoup de fois c'est plus
compliqué mais qu'on voit le résultat se
révèle à chaque fois ça nous motive pour
continuer hélas
bon donc pour le 11 et le 12 aussi on
adore parce que c'est une partie de
votre travail ce travail avec les
enfants des différents quartiers du
monde en parle et là on vous renvoie
vers le site internet de france inter
pour suivre le carnet de campagne qui
vous était consacrée à la paix m est ce
qu il ya une partie de travail aussi que
vous menez avec deux représentations 11
avril 12 avril
voilà la merise so lu ment alors l'idée
c'est comme il ya cette année on va
avoir trois cent soixante dix enfants
mais les autres donc on organise des
concerts pédagogiques avec les classes
de trappes de elancourt la verrière et
celle celles qui participent au projet
plus d'autres classes la directrice
artistique qui est maintenant mélanie
lévy thiébaut a préparé tout un document
est là on va faire une séance de
concerts pédagogiques le 11 avril matin
on va par quatre cent cinquante enfants
de maternelle et l'après midi on va
avoir deux séances avec les élémentaires
et là on va avoir 950 élèves
donc ça permet si vous voulez pour eux
d'approcher la musique classique est
l'élément important leurs familles sont
invitées le lendemain pour le concert
symphonique à la merise et là on a
maintenant un bon partenariat avec la
nouvelle équipe de la merise ce qui nous
permet en fait de monter ces spectacles
est d'accueillir tout le monde alors
qu'avant à l'auditorium de trappes c'est
un peu limité pour la musique
symphonique
merci à hervé pas fermé farges président
de l'apn est ce qu d'être venu donc sur
ce plateau nous parler de vos
différentes actualités on l'a évoqué
france inter votre site internet pour le
programme complet et tout découvrir vous
aurez l'occasion bien sûr de revenir sur
ce plateau vous êtes vous le savez ce
sera avec plaisir merci on va passer
maintenant aux sports anthony rech va me
rejoindre nous allons faire un point
complet et puis on va commencer par du
rugby d'ailleurs